[музика]
вітаємо і Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі Ми раді що ви
приєднались до нас напружена ситуація на
Близькому Сході впливає на весь світ у
тому числі і на людей тут у
Німеччині із 7 жовтня ніщо не залишилося
колишнім так сказав президент Німеччини
Штайнмаєр висловлюючи свою Солідарність
із
Ізраїлем напад на Ізраїль терористичного
угрупування хамас призвів до загибелі
найбільшої кількості євреїв із часів
Голокосту у Берліні понад 10 000 людей
вийшли на демонстрацію проти насильства
і посилення антисемітизму в
країні після нападів хамасу Берлін
пережив сплеск антиізраїльських і
антисемтських інцидентів У деяких
районах навіть відбулися жорстокі
сутички між протестувальниками та
поліцією у подібних ситуаціях Такі люди
як дервіс хізарчі та Лілі краузе твердо
переконані що помірковані та
медіаторські голоси стають усе більш
важливими вони прагнуть лагодити розколи
і загоїти біль виступаючи за примирення
і
толерантність я Лілі я палестинка
ізраїльтянка німка я дервіські зарчі
голова кройсберської ініціативи проти
антисемтизму назвіть хоч один конфлікт
чи проблему які б вирішилися
насиллям як Берлінець Я дуже стурбований
щодо подальших сутичок та ескалації
ситуації
це занепокоєння зростанням насильства
поділяє багато людей тут у Берліні
тисячі людей зібрались разом Щоб
висловити свою підтримку Ізраїлю протест
проти тероризму хамасу і Солідарність з
Ізраїлем атаки хамасу масовані авіаудари
Ізраїлю у відповідь по газі і ця
Гуманітарна катастрофа загалом мали
наслідки і тут у
Берліні поліція скасувала кілька
зареєстрованих демонстрацій про
палестинських груп
у результаті цього відбулися стихійні
збори в берлінському районі де проживає
багато
імігрантів люди кидали феєрверки а
поліція застосовувала водомети багато
людей було
затримано У той же час антисемтських та
расистських інцидентів здається стає
дедалі
більше євреї не відчувають себе в
безпеці ніколи раніше стільки людей яких
я знаю не залишали своїх дітей вдома щоб
не відправляти їх до школи чи дитячого
садочка
Я ніколи раніше з таким не
стикався дервіш хізарчі та його колеги
працюють у кризовому режимі щодня
вчителі та представники влади
звертаються до них за порадою як
зменшити напруженість між громадами
особливо в таких районах як нойкльн і
кройдсберг де проживає багато імігрантів
цікаво що у нас також ніколи не було
стільки стрбованих мусульман які бояться
що їхніх дітей Тут будуть стигматизувати
і
криміналізуватини переймаються за свою
безпеку за свої засоби до існування
Лілі краузе знає що існує багато точок
зору на ізраїльсько-палестинський
конфлікт і хоче щоб вони були почуті
Вона заснувала берлінську асоціацію за
мир на Близькому Сході яка організовує
демонстрації її батько був палестинським
громадянином Ізраїлю вона хвилюється за
своїх друзів у газі вони кажуть що без
силі щось
змінити вони кажуть менієдине що можеш
зробити будь ласка молися щоб ця війна
припинилася і я думаю що це відчуття
насправді об'єднує багатьох здоровий
глуст говорить що це насильство має
припинитися насильство це ніколи не
рішення саме тому краузе взяла участь у
демонстрації на знак солідарності з
палестинцями за її словами вона хоче
привернути увагу до страждань з обох
сторін для неї це не суперечить
державній підтримці Ізраїлю з боку
Німеччини
Ми повинні стояти на боціі Ізраїлю хай
там що але Питання в тому як стояти на
його
боці Ми повинні бути критичними
друзями а бути критичним другом означає
говорити своєму другові що бомбити
невинне цивільне населення гази Це
ненормально ця демонстрація у
кройцберзі зібрали близько 5 000 людей
різного походження щоб закликати до
припинення насильства дервіш хізарчи із
кройсберга вважає що в цей момент
високої напруженості обмін думками та
налагодження конфліктів важливіші ніж
будь-коли він хоче більше діалогу в
школах із раннього віку і Застерігає від
поспішних
реакцій Сьогодні ми повинні зберігати
спокій
і показати нашу готовність бути
відкритими для обміну
думками Ось що зараз на часі
Лілі краузе принесла другу свічку щоб
сьогодні світло світило для
всіх вона хоче продовжувати закликати
проти насильства і за мир на Близькому
Сході так само як вона робить це тут у
своєму рідному місті
Берліні
люди у Франції також шоковані у Франції
проживає найбільша єврейська громада в
Європі так само як і у багатьох інших
країнах кількість антисемітських
інцидентів Тут також зростає однак Такі
люди як єврейський пекар Ерік бінаїс
сподіваються що конфлікт на Близькому
Сході не вплине на його життя і життя
його сусіда мусульманина хейді лабаєда
Вони живуть у паризькому передмісті
сарсель протягом багатьох років тут
мирно співиснували євреї мусульмани і
християни і вони рішучості не дати
порушити цю гармонію вони тримаються
разом щоб виразити свою
підтримку Імам хасем чалгумі нещодавно
відвідав велику синагогу Парижа щоб
вшанувати Пам'ять жертв
насильства на вулиці патрулює поліція
війна на Близькому
Сході Імам був близьким товаришем жуеля
мергі протягом багатьох років євреї
мусульмани і християни зібралися разом
приголомшені останніми
подіями ісламісти варварські вбили понад
тися наших сестер братів і
дітей тепер ми можемо лише оплакувати
їх їхні думки з
Ізраїлем але ісламійські напади
продовжують впливати і на їхню власну
країну вони бояться що терористи можуть
завдати нового удару і Імам поділяє це
[музика]
занепокоєння звісно ісламісти брати
мусульмани і французькі ліворадикали
поширюють ненависть у соціальних
мережах і ми не можемо допустити щоб цей
близькосхідний конфлікт був перенесе не
сюди сарсель - це як маленький Єрусалим
з 1950х років це старе париське
передміся було домом для активної
єврейської громади з Північної Африки
яка жила разом з багатьма мусульманами і
християнами вони мирно співіснували
протягом багатьох
років але у 2014 році антисемтські
напади сколихнули сарсель Кривава
неділя
Ерік бенаїс керує кошерною пекарнею у
сарселі уже 30
років його тістечка і торти справжній
хід Але у своєму кафе у центрі міста він
помічає що настрій відвідувачів
змінюється можна сказати що з плином
часу напруження
зростає А ось і
мер Як ви
до мера сарселя приєднується префект
поліції вони роблять обхід відвідують
єврейській
підприємства Як ваші справи Чи є якісь
проблеми в інтернеті гуляєть деякі
повідомлення Це треба
перевірити неодмінно дайте нам знати
якщо помітити щось
незвичне Ерік поки що не дуже
занепокоєний Я не боюся
місцевих Я боюся молодих хлопців які
приходять з інших
районів у сарселі поліція тепер патрулює
вулиці і не лише
тут на цій пропалестинській демонстрації
у Парижі протестувальники вигукували
Ізраїль убивці цей захід було заборонено
але він зібрав тисячі людей серед яких
було багато молодих французів поліція
була на
поготові
71річний хейді лабаєт відоме ім'я у
сарселі Він любить простягати руку
допомоги ремонтуючи велосипеди або
допомагаючи сусідам він мусульманин але
не питає людей про їхнє походження чи
вірозповідання зараз Ми тут працюємо
разом тісніше ніж будь-коли
хейді керує сусідською асоціацією і
збирає все що можна використати
повторно він пристрасний майстер який
щодня працює у своїй
майстерні там він чує що місцеві жителі
говорять про нову війну яка вирує на
Близькому
Сході тут у сарселі Все буде Тихо ми
працювали над цим роками в
асоціаціях щоб не відбувалося в Ізраїлі
це не прийде
сарсель сарсель можливо і залишався
спокійним але на півночі Франції
ситуація зовсім інша там 20тирічний
чеченський джихадист здійснив
Смертельний напад із
ножем президент поспішив на Місце
злочину а Франція перейшла в режим
найвищої готовності до терористичної
загрози у сарселі сьогодні базарний день
хейді також
тут товари такі ж різноманітні як і самі
сарсельці тривожні новини та війна на
Близькому Сході схоже поки що не
хвилюють тут
людей звісно я хочу щоб всетаки
залишалося Я вдячний за свободу слова у
Франції Ми не повинні приносити проблеми
звідти Кожен може висловити свою думку
це не наша країна але ми її поважаємо
хейді переконаний що люди тут можуть
мирно
співіснувати Але чи залишиться так у
майбутньому
[музика]
Дозвольте мені познайомити вас із
давньою традицією патріархальних сіл
Албанії про яку більшість європейців
навіть не чули мова Про перетворення
жінок на чоловіків що звучить скоріше як
зміна статі для таких жінок як Юстина
Гріша це єдиний можливий спосіб стати
Головою сім'ї те на що жінки в
патріархальній консервативній сільській
Албанії наше не мали
права цих жінок називають бурнешами
клятвеними дівами Ми відвідали чи не
останню з них у лепуші в горах Північної
Албанії у таку спеку рубати дрова дуже
важка
робота але роботу треба робити зараз
каже
Юстина у горах на півночі Албанії ма
приходить
рано це важка
робота Я жінка але я сильна як чоловік і
мені подобається ця робота Я робила це
коли була молодою і Я продовжую це
робити І
сьогодні Юстина одна з так званих
албанських клятвених дів або бурнеша з
часів середньовіччя стародавні звичаєві
закони відомі як канун дозволяли жінкам
жити як чоловіки з тими ж правами та
обов'язками часто це було крайнім
заходом щоб забезпечити виживання сім'ї
оскільки тільки чоловіки могли
отримувати
спадщину коли мій батько захворів і
помер Ми вирішили що я буду допомагати
мамі виховувати
дітей Юстина склала обітницю снотливості
і відтоді вважалася чоловіком вона стали
відомою як дуні новий глава
сім'ї є багато жінок які не заміжні але
вони не
бурнеша бурнеша шанують старі добрі
традиції такі як мужність і
гостинність і ви присвячуєте себе
виключно своїй
родині І вона дійсно віддає всю себе
Юстина вже багато років забезпечує своїх
братів і сестер вони вдячні і повністю
приймають її як главу
сім'ї
її дуже поважають і вона має великий
вплив у
селі вона беззаперечний авторитет і в
нашій
родині Навіть зараз а Мені 47 років Я не
насмілююсь їй
суперечити зовнішньому світу вона відома
лише як дуні вона та її сім'я
використовують її жіноче ім'я роль
бурнеша не має нічого спільного із
сексуальною орієнтацію це суто соціальна
функція як бурнеша жінка перебирає на
себе роль чоловіка і все- каже
Юстина що
зламалося та щось з
машиною давай поглянемо а я думаю це
можна полагодити
дротом я можу допомогти тобі
пізніше столиця Албанії тирана далека
від реальності останніх з бурнеша чи
знають люди взагалі хто це
такі звісно Ці жінки такі ж сильні як і
чоловіки але по жіночому добрі
серцем бурнеша кмітливі
жінки Вони показали на що здатні навіть
під час
війни це було революцією свого
часу повернімося у гори Юстина показує
нам фотографію лалі теж бурнеша лалі
була солдаткою потім поліцейською вони
познайомилися незадовго до смерті лалі
Мені було дуже сумно тому що вона була
моєю подругою Ми були останніми
борнеша Тут у горах життя
самотнє сім'я була змушена відмовитися
від фермерства майже 10 років тому
натомість відкривши свій будинок для
туристів
дедалі більше людей відкривають для себе
красу албанських Альп
ми тримали гостьовий будинок разом з
моєю невісткою та племінниками але коли
вони поїхали ми його закрили Я вже не
молода і не можу займатися цим
сама майже вся Її родина виїхала за
кордон бо тут просто замало роботи
Юстина дуже рада що її сестри з Італії
та США приїхали до неїз подіваним
візитом кілька безтурботних днів із
сім'єю перш ніж вона знову залишиться на
самоті але Юстина ніколи не поїде
звідси це місце надзвичайної краси
створене самим
Богом тут я народилася тут я така
щаслива це місце окрилює людей які тут
живуть
Юстина знає що разом із нею помре і
багатовікова традиція але з цим нічого
не поробиш каже Вона Головне що її сім'я
продовжує жити
ні сач виноробка і має всі якості
необхідні для успішної кар'єри
виноградаря однак сач живе в Туреччині
країні якою керує консервативна партія
президента реджепа таїпа
ердогана з моменту приходи до влади
ердоган послідовно пропагує неалкогольні
напої він також підвищив податки на
алкоголь це складні умови для виноробів
Туреччини деякі з яких мають
багатовікові традиції як наприклад у
західній частині країни поблизу
болгарського
кордону шиніз сач проводить батька по
їхніх виноградниках
Це був хороший рік з великою кількістю
дощів і Сонця сач покладає великі надії
на цьогорічне червоне вино у фракії на
заході Туреччини ідеальні умови для
цього влітку тут дуже спекотно а
вочорами приємно прохолодно що охолоджує
виноград якби тут завжди було спекотно
вміст цукру у винограді зростав би надто
швидко і це було
проблемою сач її батько та брат
заснували цю виноробню 17 років тому на
родинній
землі вино у цій місцевості вирощують
тисячі років і такі вонороби як сач
хочуть відродити цю
традицію але нинішній
релігійно-консервативний уряд має інші
ідеї нам доводиться мати справу з
перешкодами на відміну від будь-якого
іншого
сектору
Наприклад ми повинні кожні два роки
поновлювати ліцензію на діяльність і
щоразу маємо за це
[музика]
платити також нам намагаються закрити
шляхи збуту Ми не можемо приїжджати на
фестивалі чи культурні заходи нам
повністю заборонено рекламувати нашу
продукцію А ще є податки на
алкоголь за останні 12 років вони зросли
більш ніж на
1500%
вино пиво тютюн все має подорожчати каже
президент ердоган затятий противник
алкоголю Ми продовжуємо підвищувати
податки на тютюн і
алкоголь але вони продовжують купувати
ракію і
пиво вони кажуть мені бай дуже я все
одно буду
купувати але винна культура - це щось
більше ніж просто пияцтво каже
сач вона проводить регулярні дегустації
на виноробні це суто приватні заходи
адже вона не має права їх
рекламувати любителі та поціновувачі
вина приїжджають аж зі Стамбула за 300
км
[музика]
звідси що стосується вина то туречина не
отримує тієї уваги на яку заслуговує Це
очевидно пов'язано з
політикою
sonüü і ми країна де більшість вважає що
Алкоголь це просто
інтоксикант сач хоче боротися з цими
упередженнями вона запрошує відвідувачів
допомогти зі збором врожаю її Мета
показати всім що це нормальне сільське
господарство а не якийсь
наркотик
у Туреччині середньостатистична людина
випиває менше літра вина на рік і це з
урахуванням 30 мльнів туристів які
відвідують країну
щороку Ані кількість тих хто п'є вино
Ані його споживання не
зростають але Попри це спостерігається
реальне зростання інтересу до
виноробства та винної
культури Але не всі в окрузі це
схвалюють
У сусідньому селі навіть не замислюються
над тим щоб робити з винограду щось інше
окрім
оцту Чесно кажучи це консервативне село
це видно з
назви наші прядки були побожними
мусульманами тому ми не п'ємо вина бо це
суперечить нашій
Вірі у турецьких сільськогосподарських
школах вже багато років не викладають
виноробство деяким працівникам
доводиться виправдовуватися
дехто запитує Навіщо ви працюєте на
винограднику гроші зароблені там не
приносять ніякого благословення це
мовляв гріх А я тут
щаслива виноградарям Теж нелегко вони
дивляться на Болгарію на
Євросоюз там винороби мають таку ж землю
такі ж сорти винограду таке ж сонце але
вони отримують
дотації не можуть продавати за цінами
які ледве покривають наші виробничі
витрати а все що нас розділяє це 20 км і
кордон Але незважаючи на всі труднощі
сач не зупиняється на досягнутому заради
успіху традиційного якісного вина
зробленого у
Туреччині Дозвольте поставити вам веселе
запитання Що зелене і вкрите білими
крапками А відповідь можна знайти у
зеленій дилії як наприклад на південному
заході Англії У котсолсі там Десятки
тисяч овець пасуться на пишних зелених
луках серед них Можна помітити одного
молодого пастуха 16-тирічного себа
годвіна Він дуже любить тварин яких у
нього більше сотні для цього підлітка
немає нічого прекраснішого ніж проводити
час зі своїм
стадом а на цьому Ми завершуємо цей
випуск Європа У фокусі і не забувайте ви
можете зайти на наш сайт або в соціальні
мережі щоб дізнатись більше історій з
усієї Європи Абсолютно безкоштовно
Дякуємо за перегляд Бережіть себе і до
зустрічі наступного
[музика]
тижня
fore